I realize a success is fleeting and as a
fighter you're only as good as your last
fight because as soon as you win the
clock starts ticking again that's what
drives me to evolve and improve every
day and everything that I do
my name is may we may has mastered more
things than most will in a lifetime her
path to greatness started back when she
took up swimming as a child May would go
on to compete in the 1992 Olympics in
Barcelona representing Singapore I was
swimming competitively for about 14
years and at the end of that I was just
really tired of the training regimen the
pressure from competition and not having
a normal life she went to college and
eventually medical school but then she
stumbled on a martial art called
capoeira fell in love with it and she
mastered that too that was her first
step into MMA MMA means mixed martial
arts you will be fighting against an
opponent in the cage but you can use any
form of martial arts that you're
comfortable with I started with capoeira
I have really good ground game in
jiu-jitsu so I like to take my fight to
the floor and I like to finish my
opponents on the floor I think I've got
most of my opponents
when I was training recreationally I got
really good and a lot of people asked me
to compete I refused to it because I
didn't want to be in that competitive
environment anymore but I met Hilah
Gracie who is royalty in the martial
arts world once he saw me train he knew
that she was destined for greatness he
encouraged her to compete and so she did
for five years becoming one of
Singapore's best fighters and now Mei is
taking time away from competition and
once again mastering something new I
work with children from two and a half
to 12 I grew up in a middle-class family
and I didn't have a lot of opportunities
but through swimming and sports I had
amazing opportunities and had a lot of
doors it opened for me now that I have
the means to give back I like to give
back to Singapore and help grow sporting
culture and Singapore
[Music]
you